Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors and for today's book review, we're going to talk about this
great book
by Alisa Childers called another gospel. It's a
great response to the CEO ladies
Attendance in a church that she went to that she initially thought was a fantastic church
And she realized that there is a
a
belief system in
quote-unquote Christianity out there. That's called progressive Christianity. It's a quote-unquote Christianity because I don't think it's Christian whatsoever
in fact, I think it's anti-Christ
And she doesn't say maybe that strongly, but I would
Progressive Christianity is a
complete different belief system. They've not believing it inherited some scripture. I think it's I think it's
Important for everybody to read this book if you're a believer and or even if you're seeking
Truth in any way because there's a lot of
wrong teachings. There's other
Gospels out there that as Paul said they are not Gospels. They are lies and they are
damnable
doctrines and
It's very important for you to know the difference and it's not okay for a believer to
To not dig into this and not discover for themselves. What is truth? I
See this so often my wife and I went through this very similar experience as
Miss Childers did. She'll she'll explain in her book that she heard her husband went to this church
They just love the church. They love the people of the church. This the worship and praise was fantastic
They liked the teaching that the pastor invited her to a more in-depth study along with dozens of other people and through this in-depth study
It was revealed to her the real
Doctoral beliefs of the pastor and that's where she started to understand what has become known as
progressive Christianity
which is really
Damable doctrines of demons. It is truly another gospel as Paul writes about that is not the gospel of Jesus Christ at all
Even though they have hijacked many of the terms hijacked many of the
the words that are used in Christianity the
The language of Christianity, but the ultimate belief system is far from Orthodox Christianity and
It is very important for believers if you're going to a church if you're trying to to understand your faith in Christ to
be willing to to
take that step of
learning some real apologetics and being able to prove your faith
So I highly recommend this book. I give it a five-star review. I think what Lisa Childers has done was has been fantastic
She also has a podcast in a YouTube channel that I'll show you a link to in just a second
Then I highly recommend that you subscribe into
Apologetics is really digging into your faith and really being able to prove your faith
And we as believers are called to do that. We're not to be lazy Christians
She is
Has a background much like many Christians do she was raised at a good Christian home by good Christian parents was taught
in a good church
Yet she was never challenged to really dig into her belief system and
Understand the reason why she believes these things and and that is important if you're going to withstand the scrutiny of the world
You have to understand why you believe these things
And it's not the faith of your just your family or your parents
It's your faith that you're standing on or you may be standing on sand
I talk about this in a book that I wrote several years ago is healthy only difference
Demand in sanctification
In our own lives and sanctification is where God takes those who
Give their life to him and he disciples us. He disciplines us. He shapes us and molds us to the image of our of his son
That's really what your life purposes as a believer
It's not to live a great life and to have a Mercedes and to have perfect health and to have wonderful things and that lived to a hundred and twenty years
Oh, that's totally self-absorbed narcissistic Christianity
Which is not Christianity whatsoever and we talk about this a lot with our patients
Cutters clinic were mainly a cancer clinic and we deal from a spiritual side that
God disciples us and he is a
God that loves us so much that he can allow
Payton suffering in this world and allows paid and suffering our lives to drive us to a deeper
sanctified relationship a more holy relationship with him. That's what our purpose is
This little sliver of time that we live here on earth is
meaningless
Compared to eternity and this we need to take this sliver of time that we have here on earth to drive our relationship closer to him
If you don't have a hugger for God's word ask him for it pray for that hugger and thirst for his righteousness
And his holiness because only he could give you that I need to pray that prayer every day because I am a
Flashly human being that seeks after my old ways all the time and
This is this book is another just another reminder to dig deeper into the truth. Don't get
Don't believe the lies of this world whether they come from a pulpit
Or a church of people that are very friendly and nice, but are the truth is not being told these are damnable things people
This is not something to take lightly. We need to seek the truth with all our heart and we need to pray for wisdom and and not be lazy about our Christian walk
If you don't have a hugger for the truth if you don't have a hugger for his word ask for it ask for that hunger only he could give you that right
Just hugger for his truth
I pray that you look up Alisa Childers. Here's her website Alisa Childers.com from there
You could get to her YouTube channel from there. You could get this book
I have both the hardcover and I listen to an unaudible and from there you can watch a bunch of her interviews and her videos
Highly recommended five star review. Don't be lazy in your walk with the Lord. You need to do some work here
Rejoice always pray without seizing give thanks in all circumstances not just things that feel good
And this is the will of God in Christ Jesus for you
First Thessalonians praying for you. Thanks so much. Bye. Bye